what's this story with biolabs Adam have
you been following this story with
biolabs here's a reuter story Russia
says USS bio Labs with plague and
Anthrax in Ukraine U.S calls claim
absurd Russia said on Wednesday the
United States must explain that what
Moscow claims was a military biological
program in Ukraine an allegation
Washington has already dismissed as
absurd misinformation Russian foreign
minister spokesperson Maria zakarova set
evidence of the alleged program has been
uncovered by Russia during what it calls
its military operation in Ukraine it
involved deadly pathogens including
plague and Anthrax you said zakarova
said Russia had documents showing that
the Ukrainian Health Ministry had
ordered the destruction of samples of
plague cholera Anthrax and other
pathogens after February 24th now let me
read the next story to you on Biden
officials say U.S working with Ukraine
to prevent bio-research facilities from
falling into Russian hands Ukraine has
biological research facilities which is
fact we now are quite concerned Russia
troops Russian forces may be seeking to
gain control of so we are working with
the ukrainians on how we can prevent any
of the research materials from falling
into the hands of Russian forces
should they approach okay so that is
being said by under Secretary of State
for political Affairs Victoria new land
okay the response came in regards to a
question from Senator Marco Rubio who
asked does Ukraine have chemical or
biological weapons follow newland's
response Rubino continue to ask the
question whether she had any doubt that
they did or not there is no doubt in my
mind Senator and it's classic Russia
Technic to blame on the other guy what
they're planning to do themselves okay
and then some of it links back to uh
Obama but I'll pause right now if you
guys got any thoughts on this go ahead
yeah so a couple of things can be true
at the same time I I just airdropped you
yeah so this is this this document that
I just airdropped this is from uh the
U.S embassy in Ukraine April of 2020 two
years ago I found this document and
scroll down a little bit to what this
press release says if you wouldn't mind
yeah so it says the US Embassy would
like to set the record straight
regarding disinformation spreading in
some circles in Ukraine that mirrors
Russian disinformation regarding the
strong U.S Ukraine partnership to reduce
biological threats but then listen to
what they say here in Ukraine the U.S
department of defense's biological
threat Reduction Program works with the
Ukrainian government to consolidate and
secure pathogens and toxins of security
concern in Ukraine government facilities
while allowing for peaceful research and
vaccine development that my friend is
first of all in admission that there are
biological Labs biological weapons labs
in Ukraine but this the reason it's so
euphemistic is because once biological
weapons research was sort of banned they
still our government still does this
they just do it under the guise of being
biodefense and you can tell when there's
a sentence like that they literally said
the U.S Department of Defense works with
the Ukrainian government for peaceful
research like defined to me what
peaceful research is because if peaceful
research is the same type of research
that the US was involved in funding and
the Wuhan Institute of virology then we
have we have a very different definition
of of peaceful here so I think that
there is for almost certain evidence
that there are biological labs in
Ukraine um that being said that can be
true and it can also be true that if
there is a biological weapons attack
that happens in Ukraine it is almost
certainly from Russia those two things
can be true at the same time that's a
very good point out I'll read this next
story about President Obama deleted web
pages show Obama LED an effort to build
a ukraine-based bio lab handling
especially dangerous pathogens this is a
national pulse story two days ago
deleted web article recovered by
national Apostle revealed the former
president Barack Obama spearheaded an
agreement leading to construction of Bio
Labs handling especially dangerous
pathogens the Ukraine originally posted
June 18 of 2010 the article biolab opens
in Ukraine details how Obama while
serving as an Illinois Senator helped
negotiate a deal to build a level 3
biosafety lab in Ukrainian city of
Odessa the article which also
highlighted the work of former Senator
Dick Luger was additionally included in
issue number 818 in the United States
Air Force counter proliferation Center
Outreach Journal so this this so so now
I've got a very different question for
you guys very different question for the
two of you so what is the what is the uh
and from the other side some people are
asking this question what is the big
deal with this meaning if
the enemy in China the one with Wuhan
lab that's very problematic because
you're you're funding the enemy to come
up with certain bio Warfare but if a lot
of people the next war is going to be
cyber and it's going to be bio shouldn't
we get smarter in this area shouldn't we
invest some money to research and get
better at this I guess what I'm asking
is why are people being uh oh no no no
we didn't oh no no no we didn't why are
people so worried is there a guideline
that you cannot do that is there a maybe
I'm missing something is there a
criteria that you cannot do and and what
is that criteria yeah this is what
happens when when well when liberals in
charge of our country make decisions
about what research is allowed or not
based on what the International
Community thinks versus what's in our
best interest there's certainly an
argument that could be made that says
well it's in our best interest to have
bioweapons right like I think that's a
perfectly valid argument I probably
would agree with that but because it's
against because it's against the law
right now because you know the gain of
function research is against the law
this juicing up of viruses or toxins to
make them more transmissible and more
lethal to weaponize them because this is
against the law it's really shocking
when people hear that the government is
violating the law for their own interest
I mean that that was the problem with
fauci right this is actually this is
actually why I think fauci has
disappeared from the airwaves because
what's happening in Ukraine is just
another example of fauci pretending that
he's not engaging in BIO weapons
research he's just doing it under the
guise of biodefense because remember the
at the NIH and the Nia ID which is the
sub-agency that fauci's in charge of at
the NIH they control I'm not joking
literally billions of dollars as it
pertains to biodefense spending so any
any biodefense funding in our country
fauci's finger is in this and this is
this is I mean it's a scandal great
great Point by the way I don't like that
we're doing it in Ukraine I don't like
it that we're doing it in China I don't
like it that that's being done and this
day you just post up right here Tyler uh
the biological weapon convention bwc's a
legally binding treaty that Outlaws
biological arms after being discussed
and negotiating the United Nations
disarmament form starting in 1969 the
BWC opened for signature on April 10
1972 and entered into force of Martial
and exclusive that's a 183 State uh
parties including Palestine and four
signatories Egypt Haiti Somalia Syria
Tanzania 10 states that have neither
signed nor ratified the BWC chat none of
those are big States South Sudan okay in
terms of BWC okay so so this says you
can't do it but now now how much has it
changed since then who's holding up to
this who's committing to this and quite
frankly do you know when people say does
Iran have a nuclear weapon you know that
whole conversation about this you don't
have a nuclear weapon I asked the
question how can you really audit
whether they do or not like let's just
ask that question how can you do it
Iran's not a small country how do you go
figure out whether they have it or not
you don't think they have some creative
places to be able to have a nuclear
weapon you don't think they're currently
working on it do you think they do it in
a structure with glass windows for
people from the outside like you know
how you go to New York and you know look
at CNN studio or Fox and it's glass you
can see somebody doing the show you
think they work on weapons like that
with glass windows for audiences oh
awesome look at this we have a nuclear
bomb being built you guys are so awesome
can I take a picture of my kids here's a
selfie so if they're doing it do we not
think America is doing it quite frankly
I don't know if I would be comfortable
with this and here's why let me tell you
why I wouldn't be comfortable with this
and it kind of goes to the Second
Amendment with me
your your pro Second Amendment yeah okay
I am too right uh this essentially is a
form of a second amendment argument
here's why
Sammy the bulgarvanov said something
very interesting to me Samuel gravano
he's a former gangster he's you know
being accused of no he actually went for
1919 murders right that are linked to
him he said the following to me about
Second Amendment he says listen me as a
gangster
go ahead and ban all guns go ahead and
ban all weapons guess what I'm gonna get
guns
I'm gonna find a way to have a gun go
ahead and do your background checks and
all the stuff you want to do I promise
you I'm gonna have a gun right okay
um
can we agree that there's a lot of
countries worldwide that can't stand
America
that if we apply the same concept right
here with Second Amendment do you not
think the bad guys are saying oh yeah
yeah yeah let's ban biological you know
labs and research yeah yeah let's do it
you're right wink we're gonna follow
your guidelines check check and then
they're going to go and say what the
hell are these naive people doing behind
closed doors everybody's working on this
because what happened the last two years
to the world was that not a you know a
not not putting a link to China or
whoever was that not a biological crisis
whoever it was and we have to still do
the investigation was that not a
biological crisis that it spread and
stopped the entire world so for me with
Ukraine of course not would China
absolutely not but do I kind of want my
military to get stronger and invest into
study and these types of things that
could potentially take our lives and
half the population can be lost and
we're not prepared for it and we're
going to say oh we were following the
rules no the other guy wasn't following
the rules and we need to renegotiate
this deal ASAP because we're not going
to sit here like a bunch of naive you
know God-fearing people oh everything's
gonna work out no only the paranoids
survive cyber warfare is going to make
people's life a hell we already
experienced what happened with Bible I
don't know I I'm going a completely
different direction I may be fully wrong
and no I I you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right and if you go
take a look at Arms reductions treaties
and you can go back to Carter and Reagan
on this salt and salt too strategic arms
limitation talks it's the same bumper
sticker that the NRA uses and it's right
if guns are outlawed on the Outlaws have
guns it's the same thing if you make a
treaty like this and by the way it was
found out in the transition between
Gorbachev and tornado right you remember
this trainica was a complete drunk
um true and they weren't concerned about
his his finger on their form of the
nuclear football that the president
carries around they were concerned about
deterioration of the Russian nuclear
missiles that were happening in silos
because they were poorly built and
that's where it was and so basically
what you have is the bad guys will
continue to work against the good guys
Pat you're absolutely right and it's not
about Second Amendment it's that no
treaty made with Russian on salt or salt
2 was not violated by the Russians it is
a historical fact they opened up silos
they looked at them when the whole USSR
you know fell became Russia are able to
look at this they're like that thing's
deteriorating in there that thing can go
off right here you can destroy one third
of this little surrounding area this way
and then Chernobyl reactor was one
example of it
we have to be doing research but
unfortunately the good guys end up
having to do it by proxy
you have to go and have Labs because the
good guys that do have glass buildings
well that's also the problem though turn
to the proxy right and the proxies are
dangerous people like the Chinese
Communists or the ukrainians I mean say
what you will about the resistance the
courage of the Ukrainian people right
now that's fine but Ukraine is a corrupt
Nation they're they're not a functional
democracy they they are not someone that
we should be sharing in my opinion bio
weapons information with there's also I
I know I keep coming back to the
corruption but there there's a
corruption that can't be ignored too
when the same person who is giving money
to you know when not to be vague here
when fauci gives money to equal Health
Alliance and they give money to the
Wuhan Institute of virology to do this
exact gain of function research when
that same agency that fauci Helms
profits from a vaccine that supposedly
supposedly addresses this virus like
that's a that's a level of corruption
and and vulnerability for profit off of
you know Mass death that I don't think
the American people want to ignore no
and by the way what I'm for is let's
investigate you know I'm for innocent
until proven guilty Jesse smallett you
know everybody was saying who he was I
don't know if you see what's going on
with him right now he's trying to get
back onto TV and acting and all this
other stuff but everybody jumped to
conclusion saying oh my gosh it's you
know Trump's campaign innocent until
proven guilty if that happened to the
guy freaking terrible that's a terrible
situation and we found out no that was
all a fluke did you see uh did you want
to say something I was just going to say
we kind of glossed over the incompetence
here that the Biden Administration has
had over a year to prepare for a Russian
invasion of Ukraine Russia started
moving troops to the Border in what
March of 2021 if not earlier and we're
just now worrying about the level three
bio lab and to evacuate it and get the
deadly pathogens out of it are you
kidding me like what what are these
people doing this is incompetence of the
highest level these things should have
been handled a year ago and it should
have when the question came up in the
Congressional hearing Victoria Newland
should have said yes it's been taken
care of we handled it six months ago
seven months ago what is that one scene
in Godfather where they try to kill
Marlon Brando uh do you know that one
scene where they had to come in uh
retaliate because can't show weakness do
you know what I'm talking about the
scene right okay so
everybody's watching to see how you
handle somebody going after your number
one guy
and they went after Biden Taliban did
and they got what they want and
everybody said well Marlon Brando and
his Camp didn't do anything well when
they after went after Trump
came after U.S Rasam soleimani the
number two guy was gone so Iran's like
let's shoot an empty place and act like
we retaliated they didn't do nothing
why okay so in sports you one of the
things that Kobe when we had him on Kobe
said I said Kobe you know if Shaq had
your work I think who would have been
who would he have been he says what he
would have been the greatest basketball
player of all time the greatest of all
time
I said why he says because he was
vicious he was physical most big guys
are not intimidating but he didn't care
he would push you he would hit you he
would do all this stuff right okay
so Shaq Trump they had a reputation of
what you do this I'm retaliating you're
gonna hear from me right so imagine all
of a sudden you try to teach a center
like Roy Hibbert hey I want you to be a
tough guy because dude I've never been a
tough guy I'm just tall what do you want
me to do I'm 7-2 don't blame me for
being seven two I'm just not a tough guy
okay I'm gonna beat you but don't do it
right relax bro chill out you're a nice
guy you're not a bad guy right Biden
doesn't know how to do that so these
guys are exploiting that opportunity of
not seeing tough it's very simple and
the enemy is capitalizing off this
opportunity so if you enjoyed this
little segment from the podcast click
over here to watch the entire podcast
and if you're not subscribed to the
Channel please do so take care everybody
[Music]